my
[Music]
uh
ex-husband is coming to visit me no no
no this is an argument
you know arala i hear about what
happened at new jersey
[Music]
so
tell your mom she said oh i'm gonna let
you tell it tell your mom what's
happened
ariella thought she could trust binyam's
sister with some information about her
ex leandro don't ask why but now the
secret she shared with her in private is
out
he's lipids just days before he is set
to arrive at her in binium's house in
ethiopia plus you're not going to keep
telling me you're going to marry your
god
if you've ever been fed up and i mean
the fed up fed up you know this feeling
that's it
i'm done with all this crap yes jenny
swung that chair during a heated
argument with submit that started
because he keeps trying to delay their
marriage luckily she didn't throw it at
him because then that
that would not be okay i don't remember
doing that i spoke to jenny about what
was going through her head in that
moment which we'll get to in just a few
but in the meantime what did you think
of the other way season 3 premiere
episode i have to fart i'll be right
back were you intrigued
bored
missing brittany is on
i don't know
how about ji hoon and devin this
neighborhood space sucks
they won't
get mad at me no not really okay well
let me know
hey 90 day fans fam it's melissa i don't
know if ariella is being mature or
playing with fire by allowing her ex to
come visit her in ethiopia i haven't
laughed this much in like such a long
time yeah i'm scared for benyam and i'm
scared for her too hopefully this visit
doesn't spark any old feelings
since benny proposed we moved into a
three-bedroom house together
and benny suggested hiring a living
nanny at the top of the episode ariella
revealed her in binium's current
situation which is that right now they
are receiving help from her parents
because binyam is having a hard time
finding work due to the pandemic
vinnie's not working at the club
but he still sometimes goes to the
studio and works on his music he sees
his friends and then he'll like be out
all night out all night i bet she won't
have that problem once leandro gets
there speaking of leandro
we talk all the time and he is really
involved in my life during this episode
he is in ethiopia but due to covet
protocol he has to quarantine for three
days before he makes his way to the
house while he was quarantining at his
hotel
ari had a nice and i mean real nice chat
with him hola
i almost called you babe because i'm so
used to
i'm saying
i don't have an ex i like that much so i
don't know if that's normal or not when
i was 19 i was living and studying
argentina when i met leandra during
their chat ari revealed more details
about their relationship and marriage
according to her they hit it off quickly
and in six months got married a marriage
that would last for 10 years i decided i
wanted to travel and he wanted to focus
on getting his doctorate oh he's a
doctor okay so we broke up
but landra and i are still best friends
oh sorry girl
it sounds like she has more complaints
about benyam than her ex who sounds like
a great catch by the way one of the most
interesting parts of it all is that
ariella wants binyam and leandro to be
friends
and she's serious when you talk to him
for a long time like you know i'm so
jealous about that like
the situation because
he's so happy you know just i feel like
you love him so much i do love him but
not in the way that you think what do
you say
i love him he's like my best friend
no you give me like more wear
no we are not together for a reason
she is really stepping into some tricky
territory here would you be open to your
current partner being friends with your
ex to specify an ex you don't have a
child with so there are no ties for me
as of right now it's a no
maybe i haven't reached that level of
maturity yet but
i just feel like when you sign up for
that there's always a risk that your ex
will say or do something that will stir
up trouble in your current relationship
i don't mind them being cordial but
friends
nah
i don't want to lose you again just like
by last relationship you know binyam
explained that he's worried because his
first wife who was also american and who
he also had a son with took their child
moved back to america and rekindled
things with her ex
which
is wild to me because although he's not
in the same situation again
it's pretty darn close
well they say if you don't heal your
past you'll keep creating similar
patterns over and over again
luckily ari seems dedicated to making
sure binium continues to have his family
around although i wonder if she ever
feels obligated to stay with him because
of what happened with his ex-wife
let's get into binyam's sisters so i
have some news that i wanted to tell you
guys they came over to the house for a
visit and that's when ari broke the news
that her ex-husband leandro will be
coming to stay with her this house
he's going to stay here he's going to be
he's going to stay in
we're going to move mimi out of his the
room and he's going to stay upstairs
they were so confused i think this is
why people we don't do that we
we don't bring our eggs in the house and
let them to sleep
you need to repair nobody ever never
invite her ex-husband
and her like new family
even i don't know why he want to come
all the way here and stay in the house
sister in the gray over here is keeping
her composure for now but just wait
she's about to pull out a secret that
she shouldn't even know about you know
ariella i hear about what happened at
new jersey
[Music]
basically told on ariella revealing that
leandro spent time with her alone in new
jersey while she was pregnant with
binium's son
what
uh what
well you didn't tell me like here last
time when you're going to was a leandro
you hangouts
yeah i know i yeah i know we did ari
stop scratching your head it makes you
look guilty he told me he stayed in your
house alone and he was five minutes or
four months pregnant oh yeah there she
goes again yeah but when i told you i
told you that which i didn't tell you
that me yeah
i know you're my great but it is
now ending it's happening again
wish it tells me things incompetence and
i tell her things in confidence like
we're developing a friendship and
because i know i didn't do anything
wrong i had no problem telling her that
well laurie now you know she is benim's
sister before she's your friend
she's gonna look out for him over you
any day
moving on i think you hide something
this new information struck benniem hard
but ariela said she didn't tell him
because she didn't want to make him
jealous i feel like now you did
something
but i didn't you slept with him no baby
i didn't sleep with him
no and funny no i know but i didn't
sleep with him it's two different rooms
two different rooms
but like i think once you guys see us
together even you maybe like once you
see us together you're not gonna be
jealous anymore you're gonna be like oh
they look like brother and sister
i know a lot of you probably just gave
off that same laugh benny and sister did
she is like yeah right
well on next week's episode leandra
arrives so we'll get to see if it's
brother and sister vibes or
if it's something else in the meantime
let's switch gears to jenny and submit
happy birthday
oh my god
before we get into the chair throwing of
it all check out this cute moment when
jenny was detailing how she felt after
submit catfished her at the beginning of
their relationship
i know that doesn't sound like it would
be cute but it was i thought that jenny
was not gonna like it that i'm indian so
i sent a picture of different person
i was upset at first but
when i finally got to see his face
[Music]
i said oh he's so cute
he's cuter than the guy he was
pretending to be
what you do oh god that had submit
feeling real nice i'm sure he could hear
her say that over and over again so
where are we going what's the surprise
you know that i have a soldier your
astrologer on jenny's birthday summit
decided to take her to his longtime
astrologer to get his take on what they
need to do to get married these two have
been trying to tie the knot since 2013
but have hit a number of roadblocks
including submits arranged marriage that
he wasn't truthful about his
father-in-law took him away from here
they didn't know he was married and his
parents objections due to jenny being 30
years older than their son jesus
[Music]
but fun fact his mom is coming to live
with him this season i can't wait to see
how that goes i believe that he could
guide us the right way to like convince
my parents to get married back to the
astrologer
jenny and submit are in a bind right now
because the pandemic has hit and if they
don't get married soon jenny's visitor
visa will force her to leave india but
as sumid just said he is still waiting
on his parents approval i don't know
whether you remember or not predicted
that
i will be in a relationship with elder
women oh so she is the women of my life
fortunate one yeah lovely lovely
i know sumit more than 20 years now
he must have been five or six years old
then that time his father actually came
that is when i told that you will have a
big trouble about this kid because his
marriage is a failure and he will surely
go for a lady with an older age what
what's his number i need to call him the
astrologer took their date of birth
information and based off of that cho
submits to stop trying to convince his
parents he also said if they want to
keep their relationship and maintain the
love between each other they shouldn't
try to force a marriage so soon let god
decide what is good for you
so you have to maintain peace and
calmness otherwise trust me i'm
predicting it today if you two will
force marriage
you two will end up fighting whatever
that astrologer says
i don't care
submit needs to marry me this is what
you say you want then let's do it keep
me here let's stay together and let's be
happy this is this is what we both want
the more you discuss the more you uh
plan out everything comes out to be a
zero at this point jenny is tired
she's not tired she's tired okay because
this has been a literal journey for her
i came here to marry you so i would
never have to leave india again so when
they got home to discuss what they're
gonna do about her visa running out
since astrologers said it wasn't time
for them to get married
she was already on edge earlier today i
got an email telling me that my visa
extension was closed instead of approved
which means that i'm gonna have to now
leave the country they tried to get
around the visitor visa situation which
says that jenny has to leave india every
six months in order to come back by
attempting to see if they could get into
a neighboring country but due to kovid
most borders were closed go against your
parents and get married then i can stay
in the country
but still if i go walking independence
you know the threat
okay well then i'm going back to america
to me that's it even though she might
not have any other choice than to leave
india jenny explained that she actually
has no home to go back to an america
because she gave up everything thinking
submit will finally marry her this time
why would i come back for the fourth
time why for what did he just say why
not why for what
i'm not gonna keep coming back and
leaving every damn six months i'm not
gonna keep doing it you're not gonna
keep telling me you're gonna marry me
that's it
i'm done with all this crap
excuse me
never listening to you again
booking my flight and i'm leaving and
there you have it
that's what led to the chair flying out
the door
but according to jenny she doesn't even
remember throwing it how do you feel
looking back at that do you remember
no that's how mad i must have been if i
threw a chair i don't remember doing
that um but you know it's been a while
since that happened and
it was just out of frustration that was
all i was just frustrated as hell
point of no return and
that's what you saw that's what happened
yeah she was mad mad but
they were sitting together so obviously
they figured something out all right 90
day fans fam thanks for hanging with me
make sure you stick with e.t because we
are covering it all i will see you next
time
[Music]